Cesar suspects mufasa's fear-based
aggression toward other dogs stems from
his owners anxiety which he confirms
when he introduces the dog to the most
dominant member of his pack a Yorkie
named Georgia peaches he's preparing to
make a move now we're gonna go in the RV
they don't let a lot of dogs come into
that stone over there so we have to do
it in my RV I'm getting a feedback from
from them it was a little growl coming
from jr. to let me know that not to
trust him and what they're saying not to
trust as his energy obviously he's
insecure if the tail was longer you were
to see tail between the legs so he's
stuck in his tail between the leg
they're not judging Mufasa by the way he
knows they just evaluated Mufasa by the
way he's entering into our circle so my
job is to make sure that no one gets
hurt
but it's also my job to listen shoot go
go see that's how he feels inside unsure
so the guys are telling me that dog is
unsure Cesar very good smell each other
feeling each other walk with each other
that closes the deal that closes the the
membership card they're now gonna be
part of the pack at the same time my
pack didn't trust them in the beginning
which rightfully so but notice how the
pack is now into the walk
the ground doing natural behavior that
means I trust in him
I mean he has relaxed
when Caesar Mufasa and Georgia peaches
returned to the boat they find Roxanne
waiting for them I just felt happy for
him every no he did it so easily but I
thought oh my god this dog that I
thought was so aggressive and so you
know dangerous or so I had to isolate so
much he's just like a calm dog walking
down the dock
well the real move us away from Roxanne
was a very insecure Mufasa and I don't
blame him I mean if he's living with
someone who loves him but doesn't trust
herself it's really hard so now we're
gonna go meet my pack
okay yes oh my god I was petrified and I
was telling Caesar I'm like well so
what's gonna happen are there gonna be
other dogs we're going to my RB but
there's anything gonna be approaching us
but I wanted to prepare already like are
they gonna be outside the RV you know
and he said why don't know I live in the
moment I'm not living in the future of
the past okay right so I'm not a psychic
they're trying to give me a lesson I'm
sure but you know we'll see when we get
there they're gonna bite him or hurt him
that would be like the worst-case
scenario right yes stationary oh so
what's the worst thing can happen if he
goes in there talk about it okay he
could get bit what's the best thing can
happen he snaps
doesn't mind being around them and stays
calm which one feel better the last us
right last I was doing through the whole
thing really nervous and and then when
he asked me to go up and open the door
I'm just gonna open that little door
that first I liked that he said you know
you're not alone here we're we're here
to support you I'm here something goes
round I'm thinking I've got Cesar Millan
here hello
entering the trailer was terrifying for
me but so I opened the door and I walked
in there drop the leash trapper sweetie
drop it trust and I was nervous but I I
saw that Mufasa wasn't getting upset it
was very strange this is life making
this actually gives you life on the
other dogs were kind of eyeballing him I
thought oh god here we go
right now just close your eyes and just
let it go for for right now just trust
go for it yeah I feel much better right
close your eyes so that's see if you
don't like that don't and that's
perfectly to acknowledge that that
became a moment of silence with tension
it was good to be able to do that but
was hard to do it I know it's hard to do
that but but I felt wow I'm sitting here
with my dog with like six other dogs
around me